[Musik]
in den wochen nach seiner abwahl braut
sich in den usa etwas zusammen
donald trump erhitzt die gemüter solange
bis die lage in washington erstmals
eskaliert wie ist es so weit gekommen
wir haben keine angst wir haben zehn
menschen durch dieses war ja und die
zeit danach begleitete brown kämpft für
donald trump bis zum bitteren ende
eine influenza in die das misstrauen in
die demokratie immer weiter anheizt
wurden unsere waren ehrlich und
anständig durchgeführt oder gab es
machenschaften hinter den kulissen
es ist zeit etwas zu sagen in atlanta
georgia fürchtet anwältin pamela pardon
sich vor dem was trump noch anzetteln
wird wir haben angst dass er in seinen
letzten tag noch etwas macht aber wir
wissen es nicht
sie vertritt illegale einwanderer die
unter der harten politik der tramp
regierung leiden
sie haben traumatisches erlebt leben und
überleben entleerten pennsylvania
bürgermeister richard ham sie kämpft
gegen die armut die arbeitslosigkeit dem
frust seiner bürger
nach der wahl gerät corona völlig außer
kontrolle
jetzt kämpft er dafür dass die menschen
erklärten die pandemie ernst nehmen bis
er selber erkrankt ich habe immer
gedacht wenn du es bekomme dann
überstehe ich das vielleicht nicht
der evangelikale pastor tal skaten ist
überzeugt jump wurde die wahl gestohlen
und die welt geht dem ende entgegen
die stimmen wurden nicht korrekt
ausgewertet während die nation im chaos
versinkt eröffnet einwanderer schuba
maradona seine tankstelle und lernen
schnell
benzin ist nicht alles die leute kommen
her tanken kommen reihen und kaufen
zigaretten und bier
[Musik]
am 6 januar geschieht das unvorstellbare
job anhänger stürmen in washington das
capitol
sie wollen die bestätigungen joe biden
zum präsidenten verhindern
angestachelt von krems war
betrugsvorwürfen prügeln sie sich ins
parlament es fallen schüsse
die welt ist geschockt das war
herzzerreißend erschreckend und hat uns
den teil amerikas gezeigt den so viele
von uns nicht wahrhaben
der frust der sich lange angestaut hat
sucht sich jetzt ein ventil die usa ein
land voller orientierungslosigkeit und
wut diese kommunisten ruinieren unser
wahnsinns land
[Musik]
mal
das ist noch nicht vorbei hört nächste
auf die aktivistischen medien wie man
kann niemals 2020 noch gewinnen
influenza in jump unterstützerin
pr-profi ihr mantra in den tagen nach
der wahl kommt wird es schaffen sofern
richtig ausgezählt wird in georgia wird
neu ausgezählt werden
das kann sich eine woche 14 wir haben
einen langen weg vor uns
ich arbeite eng mit dem team zusammen
wir hatten schon einige
telefonkonferenzen damit ist die
rechtlich in sachen alle richtig
verstehe und all das was jetzt noch
passiert diese information verpacke ich
einen botschaften die leicht zu
verstehen sind damit die leute draußen
alles mitbekommen
sie arbeitet für turning point usa eine
ultrakonservative schüler und
studentenorganisationen ganz auf linie
von donald trump sie ist gast im podcast
des gründers charly körbel wird und wenn
ich sie darum bitten armen vorlesen von
leuten die gewählt haben obwohl sie
schon tot sind und das sind wirklich
viele
freut euch drauf
uwe braun liest namen von us bürgern vor
die bei anderen wahlen betrogen haben
und verurteilt wurden
zu diesem zeitpunkt wird der sieg beiden
immer wahrscheinlicher und die rufe nach
wahlbetrug der tromp seite lauter ich
könnte euch gefolgt von informationen
auf 10 von leuten die schon vor 2020 bei
einer wahl betrogen haben
aber dieses mal ist das ausmaß so extrem
die wahlbetrugsvorwürfe gehen durch die
decke videoschnipsel auf denen
angebliche insider auspacken verbreiten
sich wie ein lauffeuer
ob die videos echt sind lässt sich auf
die schnelle kaum überprüfen
das sieht doch aus wie ein echter
wahlzettel oder ich gehe mal davon aus
das wäre doch unglaublich aufwendig so
etwas zu photoshop also auf den ersten
blick die erzählung vom wahlbetrug wird
von vielen ernst genommen
dort hat auf der anderen seite gekämpft
ein jahr lang wahlkampf für die beiden
der zwar gewonnen doch die 70 millionen
stimmen für trump machen den pastor
fassungslos
[Musik]
ich bin immer noch geschockt dass so
viele ihn sein verhalten überhaupt nicht
übel nehmen
ihnen ist es egal dass er hin kompetent
ist dass er grausam ist und dann denkst
du dir was muss denn noch passieren
damit diese leute nicht mehr die
republikanische partei oder dem
republikanischen kandidaten unterstützen
budget will endlich raus aus dem
personen wahlkampf sich wieder für
sachthemen einsetzen deshalb ist er in
washington dc kann das ein ziemlich
historisches gefühl hier das ist so leer
es wird heute eine hinrichtung geben und
gleichzeitig steht da drüben ein mann an
der straße und singt dieses ergreifende
weinhaus liegt
[Musik]
die stimmung in washington dc passt zu
dem anlass aus dem budget und seine
mitstreiter vor dem justizministerium
demonstrieren
donald trump der scheidende präsident
lässt in den letzten wochen seiner
amtszeit viele verurteilte hinrichten
doch budget steht vor einem rätsel auf
aggressive weise vollziehen sie
plötzlich todesurteile von menschen die
seit 20 jahren im todestrakt sitzen
es ist unklar wer davon profitieren soll
warum sie plötzlich so viele
hinrichtungen anordnen
aber donald trump wird am ende seiner
amtszeit so viele menschen hingerichtet
haben wie kein präsident jemals zuvor
ein zweifelhafter rekord den sich donald
trump auf den letzten metern seiner
präsidentschaft sichert
[Musik]
acht leute haben sie schon hingerichtet
vier weitere sind geplant noch bevor
seine amtszeit vorbei ist schon eine
davon findet heute statt
wir sind hier und wir nennen diesen ort
was er heute ist ein tatort und auf der
sterbeurkunde wird als todesursache mord
stehen die chancen sind zwar nicht
besonders groß aber in der theorie kann
die hinrichtung noch gestoppt werden
wir hoffen dass wir genügend
aufmerksamkeit heute nachmittag bekommen
damit doch noch eine begnadigung
erlassen wird
darauf hoffen wir immer bei diesen
hinrichtungen dass wir in letzter minute
noch ein leben retten kann
budget und die anderen demonstrieren
weiter bis zum letzten moment
ich hoffe du mal so alt bist du musst du
nicht von justizgebäude herumlaufen und
die leute zur vernunft bringen damit sie
mit dem töten aufhören
[Musik]
in harrison will im bundesstaat missouri
hat die mehrheit trump gewählt daran
zweifelt niemand missouri ist
republikaner land seit bill clinton hat
hier kein demokrat mehr gewonnen in der
grace baptist church arbeitet der
evangelikale pastor charles cave auf dem
bleiben gewinnt wäre das ein betrug
meiner meinung nach
ich glaube nicht dass die stimmen
korrekt ausgezählt wurden
ob das der teufel getan hat das glaube
ich nicht
es sind bestimmte leute die diese
arbeiten ausführen und das ist unbedingt
zu herzen
es ist samstag samstags besucht charles
gegen seine schäfchen zu hause ich will
ihnen lust machen auf die sonntags
kirche morgen die wörtliche auslegung
der bibel der strenge glauben an gott
sie bestimmen canyons leben in jedem
moment ist gottes ich hoffe dass du mich
mit deiner kraft erfüllst und ich bete
dass du kameramann sam sehen ist und ihm
gute aufnahmen beschert damit seine
chefs zufrieden sind
pastor cajun hat konservative
überzeugungen als evangelikaler ist der
gegen abtreibung und homosexualität und
ich weiß dass viele leute so denken wie
ich vor allem in der gegend wo ich lebe
hier wird mir nicht nachgestellt noch
nicht
[Musik]
mitte november gehen in washington
zehntausende trump unterstützer auf die
straße der medienmacher marge bagger
steht für traums wahlkampfspruch make
america dreckigen stoppt den wahlbetrug
lautet ein slogan
wir lassen doch nicht 51 prozent der
amerikaner bestimmen wie die anderen 49
prozent zu leben haben
so funktioniert das schlecht wir haben
keine angst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der new yorker much war eine großartige
veranstaltung die amerikaner haben ihren
patriotismus gezeigt und man konnte
sehen wie die dass die menschen sind sie
den präsidenten und seine konservativen
ideen unterstützen
auch die rechtsextreme gruppe der preis
zeigt sich aus ihrer aggressivität
machte kein geheimnis
ich komme heute abend nicht nach hause
das kann ich versprechen die furcht vor
gewaltbereiten gruppen ist kurz nach der
wahl groß dieser abend in washington
wird nicht friedlich bleiben
[Musik]
pennsylvania im nordosten der usa
briefwahlstimmen werden hier noch tage
später akzeptiert die auszählung dauert
so lang wie sonst nirgends richard ensi
bürgermeister in der kleinstadt klärten
hatte sich wegen der wahl sorgen gemacht
sich mit der polizei auf aufstände
vorbereitet doch im moment ist alles
ruhig
ich denke wenn beiden direkt am tag nach
der wahl gewonnen hätte hätten wir
probleme bekommen
aber weil es sich über drei vier wochen
lang hingezogen hat glaube ich dass die
meisten leute schon abgelenkt waren
nicht mehr so sauer
deshalb hatte sich beruhigt das war also
eher ein segen dass im januar
demonstranten das kapitol in washington
erstürmen werden davon ahnt jetzt kurz
nach der wahl noch niemand etwas klärten
freut sich über die ruhe die stadt kann
gute nachrichten gebrauchen
sie liegt im rest der usa ist abhängig
von der kohle und stahlindustrie und die
schwäche seit jahrzehnten
es war einmal eine boomregion das ist
lange her
2020 war ein jahr voller neuer
tiefpunkte großer und kleiner krisen
viele menschen haben ihren job und ihr
einkommen verloren ist und ob sie es
glauben oder nicht es fehlt uns an
spielzeug alle sind ihnen reden gerannt
ohne am spielzeug gekauft also die leute
die geld hatten
aber die leute die kein auto haben haben
nichts mehr bekommen im hauptberuf ist
laut ensi stahlarbeiter er hat glück
wurde diesen sommer nur für kurze zeit
entlassen
der bürgermeister dort hält ihn
zusätzlich auf trab
seit 17 jahren er bringt eine kiste
voller spielzeug spenden in der stadt
lädchen auch wenn es keine unruhen gab
die präsidentschaftswahl im november
hatte trotzdem dramatische folgen
verklärten und wahrscheinlich war das
auch der grund dafür
die leute hier sind rausgekommen und
persönlich zur wahl gegangen
wir als stadt klärten wir hatten im juli
ihr 60 oder 70 fälle von cobit und
hatten zwei todesfälle
heute sind es 326 und fünf tote es wurde
wirklich ernst
[Musik]
heute wird erklärten ein mann beerdigt
der hier 58 jahre lang als pfarrer
gearbeitet hat und verrät laut ensi ein
wichtiger verbündeter war in seinem
kampf die stadt zusammen zu halten
[Musik]
vor ein paar monaten hatte er sich
kobelt eingefangen
er hat das zwar überlebt aber ich glaube
sein körper hat sich davon nie wieder
erholt und der mann man nicht nur ein
referent und ein pastor in der kirche er
war ein anführer der schwarzen community
diese pandemie muss ernst genommen
werden
erst wenn so was passiert dann sagen die
leute plötzlich gibt es das wirklich und
ja das gibt es wirklich
[Musik]
pastor cajun ist dabei die kinder in
harrison will für seine kirche zu
begeistern
der gottesdienst ist zwar erst morgen er
will die eltern aber schon am vortag
erinnern was mache ich hier am
samstagmorgen
der erste grund ist weil viele eltern
sonntagmorgens arbeiten
zweitens kommen viele eltern selber
nicht mehr in die kirche
sie wollen ihren kindern helfen aber sie
kommen aus einem grund nicht aus dem
bett sonntag ist sie einziger freier tag
dafür hatten sie aus
[Musik]
natalie wie geht's ich wollte die jungs
zur kirche einladen
gross hatte ich ja letztes wochenende
habe ich verschlafen die schon rüber ja
und ich hatte mein telefon im badezimmer
vergessen aber die jungs freuen sich sie
würden gerne kommen ich rufe morgen früh
wieder an auch versuche alle aufzuwecken
es will keiner zu hause zwischen affen
die eltern wohl noch
letzte woche war tami da aber du nicht
davor die woche warst du dabei tommy
nicht was ist mit morgen so weist es
noch nicht die meisten kinder viele von
ihnen kommen aus scheidungsfamilien also
sind sie dann an manchen wochenenden bei
ihrem anderen elternteil
deshalb kommen viele kinder nur ab und
zu zum gottesdienst
die welt wird immer schlechter und die
sünde breitet sich immer mehr aus
ich würde mir wünschen dass deshalb die
leute zu dem schluss kommen würden
dass die bibel und sagt den letzten
tagen sollen wir menschen her zu uns
selbst finden und dass sie dann sagen
würden es ist zeit dass ich mich gott zu
wenden
aber anstatt der zahl der kirchgänger
wächst in harrison will die zahl derer
die an verschwörungstheorien glauben dir
gerade erst aufgestanden nichts zu sehen
ja ich habe eine idee für eine predigt
die schreiben will
es geht um co mit 19 und das zeichen des
teufels weißt du das mit bill gates mit
den robotern dem impfstoff und der
schweine dna hafen dna das hat doch was
mit dem zeichen des teufels zu tun
ja genau darüber will ich eine predigt
schreiben gute idee ich stimme dir dazu
gut das freut mich
ich sehe die kinder dann hoffentlich
morgen alles klar passt gut auf dich auf
[Musik]
hast du gehört was er gesagt hat gar
eine peer hat eine meinung zur kur wird
sache zu den impfungen die sie bald
starten wollen
das beginnt dann einen chip einpflanzen
will damit wir alle
naja auf dem laufenden bleiben
er meint es gibt viele leute die das für
ein zeichen des teufels halten dass der
teufel seine finger bei der korona krise
irgendwie mit im spiel hat dieser
meinung ist gegen auch alice die bibel
nimmt sie wörtlich und erst viel im netz
die großen nachrichtensender schaut er
nicht mehr
ich glaube den mainstream medien nicht
mehr
sie vertreten eine haltung die gegen
meine ansichten ist
ich vertraue eine nachrichtenquelle
namens newsmax
newsmax wird zum neuen lieblingsmedium
der tramp regierung als auch fox news
immer kritischer über den präsidenten
berichtet suchen seine leute nach neuen
gefolgt sängerin medien
auch isabell brown tritt bei newsmax auf
ich habe ja selbst einen
wissenschaftlichen hintergrund und muss
sagen ich bin absolut begeistert wie
erfolgreich die trump regierung den
corona wie aus bekämpft immer häufiger
werden isabelle browns inhalte zum
angeblichen wahlbetrug von sozialen
medien wie twitter oder instagram
gesperrt ich habe gerade ein video
gepostet es gibt immer ein wahllokal in
pennsylvania sowie buchstäblich stutzen
der wahlzettel ausgefüllt haben
der sinn von einer überwachungskamera
instagram hat ist sofort runter genommen
angeblich wie die community standards
hallo
umso genauer sollten wir dann hinschauen
und endlich etwas sagt auch wenn er sie
brauchen den sogenannten mainstream
medien vorwirft die wahrheit zu
zensieren sie selbst postet
offensichtlich verkürzte falsch
ausgelegte inhalte als es am abend des
million marke marge zu schlägereien
kommt veröffentlicht sie ein video das
einen angriff auf einen der rechten
preis zeigt später stellt sich heraus
dieser ausschnitt zeigt nur einen teil
der wahrheit
[Musik]
in diesem einzelfall habe ich später
eine erklärung gepostet als ich selbst
an die vollständige version gesehen habe
in der längeren version sieht es so aus
als ob die gewalt von beiden seiten aus
geht der poker verteilt selbst schläge
und drohungen bevor er attackiert wird
es ist kaum möglich in dieser szene
genau zu identifizieren wer mit der
gewalt begonnen hat isabel brown hatte
nur den teil report der den traut bei
als opfer zeigte das passiert oft in
diesen social media zeiten man weiß
selbst nicht genau was die nahe
geschichte ist dass man später das ganze
puzzle bobble braun postet jetzt auch
auf der app
hier gibt es keine grenzen und keine
sperre fahrer wird bei rechten
vertretern immer beliebter die frage die
die amerikaner uns wirklich stellen
sollten und zwar aus allen politischen
lagern ist wurden unsere wahlen ehrlich
und anständig durchgeführt oder gab es
machenschaften hinter den kulissen
atlanta in georgia
weil die wahl um die zwei senatorensitze
hier zu knapp für ein ergebnis war wird
im januar noch einmal gewählt
schon wochen vorher hat pamela pardon
ein mulmiges gefühl
es gibt auf jeden fall einer aus dass
trump in seinen letzten tagen und das
passiert ja auch schon er hat einige
gesetze geändert die das migrations
rechtsstaat beeinflussen
deshalb haben wir schon angst dass er in
seinen letzten tagen na ja wir wissen es
nicht aber es gab schon einige
änderungen die alles ziemlich aufgewühlt
haben
pamela panaro ist anwältin ihr
spezialgebiet ist einwanderungsrecht
unter präsident biden wird ihre arbeit
ein stück einfacher
das hofft sie zumindest die korona krise
bremst die arbeit der anwältin seit
monaten aus es beeinflusst alles die
gerichte sind geschlossen wir können
keine fälle abschließen die leute werden
krank es ist ein alptraum
auch wenn ihre arbeit schwieriger
geworden ist genug zu tun hat sie
allemal
die erste klienten heute kämpft gegen
ihre abschiebung
[Musik]
die festnahme der dreifachen mutter
durch die polizei kam völlig
überraschend mitten in der nacht die
polizei kam um vier uhr morgens zu ihr
nach hause sie haben eigentlich noch
jemand anderem gesucht
den haben sie nicht gefunden deshalb
wurde sie dann verhaftet
ihre kinder waren zu hause sie war nackt
die polizei zwang sie auf den boden
natürlich war sie aufgebracht
durcheinander denken sie an die beiden
kleinen kinder sie haben ein
unglaubliches trauma erlitten
drei monate lang saß die frau im
gefängnis bis pamela pelosi immerhin aus
der haft holen konnte der versuch die
abschiebung anzufechten ist vorerst
gescheitert
abgelehnt durch die staatsanwaltschaft
die unter der obama regierung gab es
einen ermessensspielraum der
staatsanwaltschaft damals war das so
dass wenn jemand schon lange da ist
kinder hat dann könnte derjenige
hierbleiben haben under unter der tram
regierung wurde das vom tisch genommen
also gibt es das nicht länger und
deswegen werden so viele deportiert die
nichts verbrochen haben die zukunft
ihrer kinder macht der klienten die
meisten sorgen
sie fragen mich gehen wir in ein neues
land was machen wir da wir sind dann
unsere freunde und du denkst dir ich
hätte gerne die antworten aber ich habe
sie nicht weißt du wer am meisten unter
diesem einwanderungssystem leidet die
kinder leiden am meisten unter diesen
ganzen sachen rassistische hetze und
eine harte politik gegenüber
einwanderern dafür ist donald trump
bekannt und trotzdem wurde der präsident
von überraschend vielen latinos gewählt
der einzige grund der mir einfällt ist
die tatsache dass viele dieser
einwanderer aus ländern kommen die von
diktaturen und sozialismus geprägt sind
sie fliehen davor sie versuchen davon
wegzukommen
also kommen sie in die usa und wenn sie
mit propaganda von einer partei
konfrontiert werden die die andere
partei mit sozialismus und radikalismus
in verbindung bringt dann tendieren sie
natürlich zur republikanischen partei
ich denke sie sympathisieren mehr mit
der partei als mit das ist die einzig
logische erklärung die mir dazu einfällt
die gerichtsverfahren die wegen des
angeblichen wahlbetrugs angeschoben
werden verunsichern auch pamela panade
und ihre kollegen
wer wird denn die neue regierung sein du
wissen wir das noch nicht nein gott steh
uns bei
[Musik]
erklärten pennsylvania hat bürgermeister
richard ham sie gerade seinem alten
freund die letzte ehre erwiesen
corona gerecht mit einer auto parade auf
der straße läuft er dem sohn des
verstorbenen pfarrers über den weg was
ich dir noch sagen wollte und das hat
jetzt nichts mit politik zu tun oder
dass ich bürgermeister bin dein vater
war ein toller typ
viele leute in der stadt vor allem mit
so einer großen schwarzen community
respektieren den bürgermeister er nicht
du weißt schon wer ist denn dein vater
hat mir immer diesen respekt gegeben und
viele leute haben auf ihn gehört jetzt
habe ich eine großartige beziehung mit
der ganzen stadt
denn vater hatte viel damit zu tun und
ich habe immer gesagt ich wünschte ich
könnte so gut sprechen wie er mein vater
war 780 und einer kurve den erwischt und
viele leute glauben immer noch es wäre
ein witz ich arbeite er beim militär
wir werden im moment in den altenheimen
eingesetzt und das ist kein witz wenn
alles vorbei ist lade ich euch zum
abendessen ein okay ich halte eine menge
von euch
[Musik]
es gibt viele theorien dass die
regierung ein chip in dein körper
stecken will dass sie wissen wollen was
wir machen und wo wir sind und viele
leute denken der impfstoffes neuer dass
wir laborratten sind wenn wir jetzt den
impfstoff kriegen würde ungefähr ein
drittel von klärten sagen nein danke der
bürgermeister von klärten ist selbst ein
risikopatient zwei krebserkrankungen hat
er hinter sich dann im dezember erwischt
sowie 19 auch ihn
ich habe bei der arbeit und im rathaus
immer die maske auf gehabt und abstand
gehalten
leider haben uns dann meine enkelkinder
zu mir nach hause gebracht
ihr vater hatte sich eingefangen als er
unterwegs war in einer bar
er hat nicht daran geglaubt dass es eine
echte bedrohung ist so kam es in mein
haus
seine letzte chemotherapie sitzung ist
gerade mal ein jahr her
ich habe immer gedacht wenn ich bekomme
dann überstehe ich das vielleicht nicht
zitiert henzi muss pause machen
[Musik]
in erbitten einer kleinstadt in georgia
bekommen super mario oder kaum etwas mit
von großen politik und war chaos
er hat andere sorgen oder besser einen
riesen grund zur freude seine tankstelle
macht endlich auf vor fünf jahren kam er
über die mexikanische grenze illegal ins
land
heute hat er eine arbeitserlaubnis und
ein eigenes business allein mit benzin
macht man kein geld das wusste schon
lange
die zusatzangebote machen den
unterschied
seine kunden hat er schon genau studiert
die leute kommen her tanken kommen rein
und kaufen zigaretten und bier
deshalb hat schuba meinen ganzen raum
für das bier angebot freigeräumt seine
bier höhle die leute langweilen sich
schnell wenn sie immer nur dasselbe
bekommen
wenn es also etwas neues gibt etwas
ungewöhnliches was du dir selbst aus
denkst dann sagen die leute guck mal die
haben eine bier höhle so ein kleiner
trick für das unterbewusstsein ist das
bei seiner monatelangen suche nach der
richtigen tankstelle hat der teenager
getroffen
er ist inder wie schubert ist aber schon
ein paar jahre länger in den usa
[Musik]
die beiden ziehen die tankstelle
gemeinsam auf teilen sich die arbeit die
kaution und sogar eine wohnung für
teenager waren die usa schon lange das
land in dem er leben wollte ich mag
alles das wetter die orte die staaten
die ich besuche alles ist großartig
nur manche regeln und vorschriften für
dich nicht so gut aber ab und zu erleben
die beiden inder auch rassistischer
begegnungen in den letzten jahren hat
das zugenommen sagt kabinett tram
präsident geworden ist hat das ein ganz
anderes level erreicht erst vor kurzem
in einer bankfiliale
wir wollten ein bisschen geld nach
indien schicken
und da meinte der typ dann ihr braucht
die sie braucht das aber er hat sehr
leise gerede
wir konnten ihn nicht hören ich habe ihm
gesagt wie bitte
ich habe sie nicht verstanden sagte er
diese verdammten inder ich war so sauer
aber ich konnte nicht sagen man will ja
nicht einen großen aufriss machen wir
nehmen denen die möglichkeiten wieso
sollten sie da nicht sauer sein
sie kommen aus einem anderen land machen
hier ein business auf junge leute in
meinem alter hier mitte 20 die machen
ihre acht stunden jobs oder gehen noch
aufs college
ich habe nicht mal ein high school
abschluss wie lange schuhbaum in den usa
bleiben darf weiß er nicht seine
arbeitserlaubnis muss er alle zwei jahre
erneuern lassen
florida im dezember in palm beach hat
die ultrakonservative organisation
turning point usa zu einer konferenz
geladen
hey leute hier ist uwe braun von turning
point usa ich freue mich riesig dass ihr
alle hier seid schüler und studierende
aus dem ganzen land reisen an
in florida ist so eine große versammlung
auch in corona zeiten erlaubt unter
auflagen das ist unsere große
jahreskonferenz in florida normalerweise
kommen bis zu 5000 schüler und
studierende her
dieses mal wegen kurve tragen wir nur
eine begrenzte kapazität aber wir freuen
uns sehr dass alle am jahresende noch
einmal herkommen das event wirkt wie
eine groß angelegte tom
werbeveranstaltung tram flogen überall
als redner werden seine engsten
vertrauten erwartet und doch muss ist
braun im interview plötzlich genauestens
darauf achten auf abstand zu trank zu
gehen
meine zukunft hängt von niemandem ab der
gerade im oval office sitzt
ich bin eine unabhängige content
produzenten und ich arbeite mit vielen
organisationen auch außerhalb der
parteienlandschaft zusammen hiervon
turning point of sale sind eine
gemeinnützige 501 c 3 organisationen das
kurz für die leute in europa zu erklären
wir sind nicht an eine bestimmte partei
oder einen bestimmten kandidaten
gebunden
was wir also tun ist viel größer als
eine person die alle paar jahre für ein
amt kandidiert wir versuchen die
amerikanische kultur zu gestalten so das
offizielle statement turning point you
say darf als non-profit-organisation
eigentlich keine politischen kampagnen
betreiben
ich glaube das ist im moment das größte
treffen auf dem ganzen planeten das ist
doch ziemlich cool wie geht's euch
bringt mal dirigiert war so ja was in
der halle geschieht ist eine andere
sache
denn hier geht es immer wieder um
unterstützung für tom denn noch
amtierende us-präsident meldet sich
sogar persönlich charlie es tut mir leid
ich weiß du bist gerade mitten in seiner
rede aber das hier kann nicht warten
[Applaus]
juni vor
[Musik]
doch mit eva braun über donald trump zu
reden jetzt wo es so viel zu besprechen
gibt geht das plötzlich nicht mehr
kannst du über die wahl reden nicht
wirklich turning point hughes ist eine
non-profit-organisation also rechtlich
gesehen dürfen wir nicht über eine
bestimmte wahl sprechen was erhoffst du
dir für donald trumps zukunft also ich
muß er selbst vorsichtig sein speziell
wenn ich über donald trump
das ist ja unsere non profit event ihr
ich kann allgemein sprechen über
konservative und demokratische themen
aber sonst glaubst du dass joe biden als
neuer präsident vereidigt wird
oder wird etwas anderes passieren ich
kann ich ja ich kann über laufende
rechtsverfahren nicht sprechen ja doof
ich lebe diesen gameplay war für den
nächsten tag hat sich vize präsident
mike pence als sprecher auf der
veranstaltung angekündigt
in pennsylvania ist es tiefster winter
geworden erklärten versinkt tage lang im
schnee
bürgermeister richard laut ensi hat
seine quarantänezeit überstanden und 19
hatte für einige wochen die komplette
familie im griff ich meine frau meine
mutter mein vater meine schwester meine
andere tochter ihr freund wir alle
hatten kurve zum glück haben wir es alle
geschafft wir waren ziemlich krank
[Musik]
tfts rich ich habe noch vier tage
durchgehalten ihm geholfen dann ging es
bei mir los ich wollte ihn ins
krankenhaus bringen aber er sagte nein
ich sagte warum gehst du da nicht hin
lasst uns testen lasst uns etwas machen
er hat es ohne behandlung geschafft und
macht sich endlich wieder auf den weg
richtung rathaus
ich habe zwei krebskrankheiten überlebt
und jetzt komm ich glaube gott sagt mir
du hast noch einen job zu erledigen
es gibt noch was dass ich zu ende
bringen soll wieder alles beim alten bei
mit châtelet henzi seit 17 jahren
bürgermeister im nebenjob für 80 dollar
die woche wenn es nach ihm geht kann das
alles genau so bleiben
[Musik]
felix wie geht's dir ich will heute noch
etwas erledigen
vor dem weißen haus in washington dc ist
es abend geworden
um 18 uhr wird brandenberger in indiana
durch die giftspritze getötet
eine hinrichtung mehr auf donald trumps
weg der präsident mit den meisten
exekutionen aller zeiten zu werden
[Musik]
fast niemand will über die todesstrafe
reden die leute wollen nicht mal wissen
dass sie durchgeführt wird
es ist den leuten unangenehm darüber zu
sprechen sie wollen nichts darüber hören
wir werden aber nicht tolerieren dass
man uns sagt so ist das system nun
einmal diese systeme werden gemacht und
unterstützt von leuten die individuelle
entscheidungen treffen
und jetzt ist es an john kamera wenn sie
in diesem haus dahinter uns arbeiten
dass sie alles tun um die hinrichtungen
in diesem land und alle formen von
gewalt zu stoppen
sie protestieren so lange bis es zu spät
ist
[Musik]
genau auf diesem platz hat dank budget
seine wahlkampftour begonnen
im januar 2020 vor fast einem jahr
es ist viel passiert mittlerweile heißt
der platz bleibt life center plaza und
davids kampf gegen donald trump ist
immer noch nicht vorbei das schwierigste
für uns in dieser zeit nach der wahl
wird es sein dass wir alle zugeben
müssen dass wir alle unser land
beschädigt haben
es ist einfach zu sagen die anderen sind
schuld
es ist viel schwieriger einzusehen dass
wir auch schuld auf uns geladen haben
und das wird die größte aufgabe für uns
wir haben uns alle in den bann ziehen
lassen haben uns gegenseitig verletzt
und unser land genau so manche haben es
aggressiver getan als andere aber es ist
uns allen passiert das wird ein
schwieriger prozess darüber zu reden
die wahrheit zu sagen und uns dann zu
versöhnen
in der halle in palm beach beginnt eine
martialische show später wird auch mike
pence hier noch auftreten
guckt euch diese dreckigen kommunisten
an
ich bin es satt dass diese kommunisten
und saoirse land ruinieren
[Musik]
die man
ich muss euch das nicht sagen aber für
all das was war und was wir noch tun
müssen
chemnitz weiter stehen weiter für unsere
wahlkämpfe weiter für die wahl in
georgia kämpft weiter an jedem folgenden
tag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir werden weiter gewinnen der
wochenlange angeheizte frust über den
angeblichen wahlbetrug entlädt sich am 6
januar
während im kapitol in washington dc die
wahl joe biden zum präsidenten
zertifiziert werden soll
prügeln sich protestler ins parlament 4
trump unterstützer und ein polizist
sterben
es war herzzerreißend erschreckend und
hat uns den teil amerikas gezeigt den so
viele von uns nicht wahrhaben wollen
die menschenmassen vor dem kapitol
angestachelt von donald trump auch die
organisation turning point you say hatte
busreisen zu der demonstration
organisiert als gewalt ausbricht
distanzieren sie sich plötzlich als er
dort seit empfehlen wir euch von dort
sie verschwinden
das ist nicht das wofür wir als
konservative stehen wir bekommen gerade
viele mails von leuten die schreiben
dass sie jetzt zu waffen greifen werden
aber ich sage euch was ihr werdet
verlieren
okay das ist eine dumme idee ja eine
menge leute sind sauer aber dann
versucht doch die möglichkeiten zu
nutzen die wir jetzt schon haben
versucht meinetwegen eine friedliche
aufspaltung der staaten zu erreichen
aber so etwas genau das nutzt doch nur
den linken
wir wollen alle immer sagen das ist
nicht amerika aber es ist amerika es ist
sicher nicht der teil den wir an der
macht haben wollen aber es ist ganz
sicher ein teil von amerika
[Musik]
das neue jahr beginnt ein neuer
präsident ist gewählt die vier jahre
unter donald trump haben das land weiter
polarisiert
[Musik]
die usa eine aufgewühlte nation ein land
auf der suche nach normalität nach sich
selbst nach einem neuen gemeinsamen
traum
es scheint fast unmöglich
[Musik]